[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est la journée du fromage
je vous le dis c'est la tablette aura
réussi à faire arriver le fromage le
plus rapidement d'un côté à l'autre qui
aura le droit de réponse d'accord c'est
très fort
oui ça c'est la piscine ou fromage
l'équipe gagnante des signes aura à la
fin l'adversaire qui devra porter un
collier de fromage jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission allô coller de francs grâce
ici le col et fromagers non mais bon on
ne jette pas vraiment japon ne change
pas de combat je vous le dis je suis
très heureux d'être avec vous ce soit
puisque ce soit je vous le dis c'est
l'anniversaire de kelly
[Applaudissements]
alors à la halle à 28 ans kelly merci je
suis hyper content pour toi ça te fera
ça te fait plaisir
oui ça me fait très plaisir alors massa
28 ans mais comme le fait oui ça me fait
alors contre le fait je lis franchement
oui on a la paix le temps voilà je
voulais tous les terrains j'ai juste un
petit gâteau voilà tout ça j'ai pas que
j'ai pas grand chose je veux dire
vraiment la vérité on appelle d'entrée
pas un truc mais on va préparer un truc
très vite je fais un petit truc sobre
d'accord mais sur féret c'est
l'anniversaire de caddie c'est une
petite souris dans un petit gâteau c'est
rien du tout st gall ancienne
présentatrice de jt va jouer dans le
téléfilm meurtre à omaha beach à la
bonne réponse mélanie version de kenny
bel anniversaire qu'elle
[Applaudissements]
contre quoi florence foresti
face à blake allez on y va
contre les voyous contre quoi florence
foresti at elle poussé un gros coup de
gueule allez on y va vite il faut le
faire quand même dépêché en éliminant
les mains sans les mains et agathe et
quévy le passage de rodez la non alors
florence le reste et pousse un coup de
gueule contre les kiosques à journaux
qui diffuse des magazines pornos mais
non non c'est pas tout à fait ça les
îles les les loges un coup de gueule
contre le magazine porno dont on voit en
kiosque l'image en gros étaient
inaccessibles du tout aux enfants je
prends cette réponse est les couvertures
à la toussaint twitter contre les
couvertures de magazines de charme hier
sur son compte instagram florence ont
réussi à pousser un coup de gueule
contre les affiches pornographiques
qu'on peut voir sur lecture ce que
parisien elle a déclaré est-ce qu'on est
obligé de se taper ça tous les jours sur
nos kiosques
pour mémoire les enfants des yeux et un
cerveau donc là ça la dérange et c'est à
nous il y en a sur la plage ans est papa
pour la mer' omg fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faudra dans quelle émission à tomber
noir je peux pas la célèbre chanteuse
américaine anastacia les fesses à l'aise
au final et anastasia c'est ça
normalement vous oubliez le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin la scène danse avec les stars
italiennes exactement dans sa cliente
déjà
[Applaudissements]